[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
surprisingly enough
i suppose there is uh my philosophical
interests
uh and throughout my life and the long
career
have centered on the question of
disagreement and difference if you
wanted to find this sociological or
personal reason for that it goes back to
my history as
someone belonging to a multiplicity of
cultures and languages
political systems and i have always
perceived these differences
and disagreements in the background of
my life and have
wanted to find philosophical as well as
personal answers to the difficult
questions that they raised
so let's take relativism first
one of the main motivations for
relativism going
back to protagoras was
the fact that there are so many
disagreements among people people
disagree about whether the wind is cold
or
hot people disagree about politics they
disagree about
ethics they disagree about what is there
out there in the world
etc etc and some of these disagreements
are
intractable they cannot be resolved
uh how are we going to respond
to these intractable disagreements well
relativism is one response
there are disagreements we all know that
so you can either say that only one side
is right
or you can say that both sides of the
disagreements are right
one according to his or her cultural
and sociological and framework and
background
and the next according to his or her own
very different
cultural or social or cognitive
framework
so that solves in some ways the problem
of disagreement
uh now how does that relate to trust
okay so when i was thinking about
disagreement in this
wider context with the
start of political upheavals in western
democracies
with brexit and trump etc etc
the question of disagreement among
scientists pure disagreement
something that as a philosopher i was
familiar with
started to have a very direct influence
on
our lives and our own choices and on
public discourse in general
so i started looking at that particular
issue
through a research project called when
experts disagree
the project was well multi-disciplinary
between a scientist and the philosopher
but had a practical dimension we just
wanted to see how
we can understand the phenomenon of
disagreement among scientists
and then more or less all hell broke
loose
and we had a
series of backlashes against experts
whether it was on climate science or
gastric
economies etc and i began
looking into the question in much more
detail
and in a more practical sense in every
sense that was relevant to
empirical work being done in these areas
and at that stage
i realized that the issue of
disagreement about
science or disagreement among experts
actually boils down to question of trust
trusting experts
which of these disagreeing sides do you
trust hence my work with relativism
ended me in in in work in
on trust
[Music]
the project when experts disagree was
fundamentally just about that about
instances of disagreement between
experts experts with
similar background and similar training
and
similar understanding of issues uh and
they're coming up with very different
uh conclusions they were particularly
interested at that time in question of
climate science
but but in fact the series of studies
that we did showed that
or supported the view that there is
relatively little disagreement among
climate scientists
or other case study was uh disagreement
among astrophysicists
they found out that there was far
greater disagreement among
astrophysicists than climate scientists
but astrophysics does not have any
political consequences so no one pays
much attention to their work
but then gradually as i said this this
uh
study culminated in the question of
trust in
science and currently uh we
are i'm running a large
european commission project called
peritea
or policy expertise and trust in action
about multi-disciplinary project with 11
participating countries
where we are focusing on the
markers for trusting experts
uh the public opinion on trusting
experts
and also steps to take to establish
trust for the relationships between
the public policy makers and the experts
so so what we think now what we are
focusing now
is not just question of trust but
but we have turned it into the question
of trustworthiness
we should not blindly trust anyone so
that
that applies to all areas we should only
trust those who are trustworthy
so the question we are asking what are
the markers what are the conditions
what are the criteria of trustworthiness
and not just how and when we trust
others including experts so there are
some
standard well-known criteria for
trustworthiness
efficiency reliability honesty
etc etc and those those criteria
are established on basis of track record
background education uh performance
and so on but also we think that looking
at the
political scene today
[Music]
many experts and policy makers may have
underestimated the role of
firstly emotions or affects and secondly
role of values in establishing trust and
trustworthiness
various studies uh including those done
by one of
my colleagues in the project bobby duffy
at king's college
london have shown that people actually
perceive
trustworthiness in terms of not just
these formal criteria of competence and
uh track record etc but also in terms of
group
values and group emotions trust involves
a feeling a sense of vulnerability when
you trust someone you're
taking a risk you make yourself open to
betrayal
trust always is accompanied by the
possibility of betrayal
and it's that possibility that should be
taken account
in the relationships between people
or to be trusted or wish to be trusted
and people who do the trusting
and i think maybe somewhat
controversially that this
applies to experts just as much to our
parents and friends and children
etc
[Music]
well some people think that we don't
really
we can't talk about trust in experts as
susan howie uh excellent philosopher
working on trust in
edinburgh thinks that we should just
rely on talk about reliance on experts
as groups rather than individuals they
think that that
experts or trust is a question of uh
a relationship between individuals
rather than groups when it comes to
experts the way expertise works
at least in policy-making conditions uh
it's groups of experts that give policy
advice but you see that in
their current circumstances probate 19
and the question is can we really talk
about
trusting groups or should we only talk
about
trusting the individuals within groups
also in various psychological and
political studies of
expertise there has been very little
attention
to the question of affect or emotions
and the
question of values up to now we have
been doing
uh quite a wide-ranging survey of these
views
and we don't find much discussion of
these affective and
normative or evaluative considerations
in approaches to trust by political
scientists
and even a time psychologist so it's
controversial in that sense as well that
not many people have done it
[Music]
so our project has three steps the first
step and last
step you're currently engaged in is
purely theoretical
we are looking at philosophical
sociological and psychological
literature on
trust in experts the second phase is
empirical
we are and that's going to start quite
soon we are going to do surveys
in normal ways in ways that have not
been done before to at least to some
extent
and also lab experiments
using behavioral economics approaches
and then once we have the results of all
of these
will enter the third phase and my view
in a way
this is the most important phase where
we try
to establish direct linkages between
experts
and the general public and policy makers
through the so-called minifora or
citizens assemblies
at small scale the strategy here
is to bring groups of ordinary lay
people
together with experts place them in one
to
in direct contact with each other and
to start conversations between them and
to try
and see if this helps in establishing
trust
between the experts and the known
experts
i think this is the way to go to
strengthen democracy
in all sorts of areas it had the the
steps have been taken quite successfully
in ireland
when it came to the very difficult
abortion referendum and the equal
marriage referendum
and i think we can do the same for
smaller but equally important questions
of
the role of science in our public life
[Music]
democracy is supposed to
take into account or be affected by the
voice of the people
one of the issues that exists there i
have to admit it about
the role of experts in uh policy
decision
uh is that experts
are not elected they are not
one of the people by definition they
they know more about
a particular subject matter than the
general
population and yet they are to have a
direct
impact on our lives and on policy
decisions that will affect our life
so a citizen assembly in that particular
instance
in the case of experts and policy
decisions
would allow the voice of the people to
be heard
more directly it will allow
dialogue between policy makers and
the general public in a very in a live
an ongoing fashion citizen assemblies
are
supposed to be based on conversations uh
rather than a small group making
decisions
and then putting those decisions to vote
so it's a way of
overcoming some of the deficits of a
democratic system
when that democratic system is being
implemented
in very large and technologically
advanced societies
in particular it's a way of establishing
a connection
between people and the governance
or the system of governance in place
that's why it can be applied to all
sorts of issues all sorts of questions
from school to large and it has proven
to be quite effective
until such time that the more effective
method is found
well no that that that would be exactly
the wrong way to go
and that will give credence to the
uh objections of the populists uh
political leaders to relying on
expertise
uh to to have a plutocracy or a system
where
experts are governing even some a few
aspects of our lives let alone all
aspects
would be a form of dictatorship actually
even though it might be an enlightened
form of dictatorship but once you cut
the voice
of the general public then you don't
have a democracy
anymore and there's no reason to think
that they will make the best judgments
they may be quite versed in their areas
of expertise
but even experts themselves would admit
that it's give and take
opposition disagreement putting your
ideas to test
those are the best ways of improving
scientific expertise and also the best
way of improving
governance in general
interestingly i think the horrendous
events of the pan
events of the pandemic have improved
so far the relationship between experts
and the general public even
michael gove who famously questioned the
role of experts and said who needs
experts
now relies on experts now there are
dangers to that
i think some governments they have seen
examples of that in many different
countries
do blame their errors on experts
secondly experts
in this in this case in case of
pandemics medical experts
virologists etc like all scientists
are prone to errors uh what the advice
they give
cannot be 100 correct and
their heirs will have her and could have
horrendous consequences so they are
placed in a particular particularly
difficult
position right now because
there is so much uncertainty around
this new virus
any advice they might present is going
to be
inevitably provisional but will have
negative consequences once it's proven
to be wrong
so so we are we are witnessing a very
interesting moment
in the connect relationship between
experts and the general public
on the one hand the general public more
than ever
is showing trust in experts and this has
been backed by various surveys that have
been taken
around in european countries and in
america on the question of kobe 19 and
trusted
experts on the other hand the
position of the experts is incredibly
precarious right now
because they can't be turned into
skateboards and also
they are inevitably going to give some
incorrect
advice or some over cautious advice
and then going to be blamed for their
errors
and that can have long-term impact on
the connection between
experts and the lay people
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you